hey guys today I'm going to talk about
in my opinion high possibility of holder
getting back in season seven based on a
few interviews in which Christian earned
an actor that plays those known as older
also will confirm his character's
appearance in the upcoming season
as well now holder was a simple-minded
servant of House Stark who was capable
of saying all in one word holder rituals
seemingly nonsense word but in the
process it became the name everyone used
the : holder is derived from the phrase
hold the door the words that young
Welles heard during the seizure that
mental disabled him as a result of the
Future brain stark working into his
young self during a vision the words
which led holder to death which
according to the showrunners ended with
holder being torn apart by the Horde of
whites while holders death was tragic
and probably the saddest moment in game
of Thrones series as his condition and
his death were accidentally caused by
bran
whom holder cared about more than
anybody else holders come back as
reanimated corpse as the white would
make holders character are achieve more
tragic but that's something that they
most likely are going to see let me just
make it clear holder definitely died but
while there's a possibility that holder
was torn apart by the whites there's
also huge possibility of holder being
only killed and raised from the dead by
the white walkers which is definitely
not beyond the realms of possibility as
the White Walkers have power to
reanimate the corpse from the dead to
act as their minions in order to
increase their army which would mean
that holder might be a part of the
knight king's army and that we are going
to see him in either the upcoming or
most likely in the last eighth season as
the White Walkers wither White's most
probably won't cross the wall until the
season 7 finale the actor that portrays
Holder had an interview with the
Entertainment Weekly popular magazine
that covers film television music books
and much more however in that interview
Kristian Nairn left a bit of doubt about
whether holder actually died nan was
asked to reveal his opinion on how his
character holder went out on which she
replied with the interesting thing is
it's kind of left open you don't
actually see him die it's implied so
who knows he may come back as a white
Walker maybe he got away in an interview
with The Independent Christian and was
asked about possibility of holder being
back as the part of the net Kings Army
in the upcoming season on which she
replied with I have no idea as much as I
would like to come back and play a white
Walker I think it would be wrong there
are too many motions tied up it will be
a bit of travesty to bring him back if
they're going to do it I'm sure they'd
find a really cool way to do it whatever
happens it's probably not going to end
well a zombie holder is not a pretty
thought both of those news replies
remind me a lot on Jon Snow and his
comeback as an actor that plays John
himself along with a huge amount of
other main characters for convincing us
that John is dead and won't be the part
of the upcoming seasons while the actor
the plays Jamie Lannister in Game of
Thrones series Nikolaj coster-waldau
replies on whether Jon Snow is dead or
not while being interviewed by one of
the most popular television host Jimmy
Kimmel Nikolaj replied ironic Louis he
was stabbed 50 times in the heart he is
dead
pointing out that Game of Thrones series
isn't a fairy tale but yet as we all
know Jon Snow was resurrected in the
first episodes of season six let me
remind you once again that I'm not
expecting from showrunners to bring
Holder back to life as they brought back
Jon Snow but there is a huge possibility
of holder being raised from the dead by
the White Walkers just as the night King
raised all the slain wildlings up as the
undead whites it's simply raising his
arms won Game of Thrones fan message me
yesterday and asked if there's any
possibility of the blue eye in the end
of recently published official promo
being an eye of the seas holder who
might has been reanimated by the White
Walkers in my opinion the blue eye in
the end of official promo entitled Long
Walk definitely is an eye of the night
King because as I've already said in my
previous video that promo trailer
contained only a Queen's and the King's
I understand why huge amount of fans
questioned the accuracy of my statement
as I said in previous video that the
blue eye is an eye of the night King due
to fact that official promo featured
only the kings and the queens which many
times questioned mainly because of the
fact that we can only see a
of the night King which some believe is
because of an eye not belonging to the
night King but in my opinion is
definitely not the case the reason that
led the showrunners not to show an
entire face of the night King is in a
fact that they wanted to share with us
one detail of tremendous importance
which is the reflection that they can
clearly see in the eye of the night King
we can see the ball reflected in his eye
which in my opinion will be one of the
last scenes of the upcoming season since
I don't expect to see night king and his
army marching south before the season 7
finale and therefore I don't expect to
see the night king south of the wall
during the upcoming season let me know
your opinion about holders fate do you
think that holders role ended with him
holding the door and fulfilling his
destiny or do you think he has been
raised from the dead by the White
Walkers and is now part of the night
king's army let me know European about
all of this in the comment section down
below hope you guys enjoyed this video
if you did please make sure to subscribe
to our Channel and I hope to see in the
next peace
[Music]